peter king suggested in yesterday's
football morning in america that the
49ers possibly have warmed to the idea
of trading jimmy garoppolo during the
draft after they picked their next
quarterback if so
need to need to sell jimmy g a little
more aggressively to other suitors and
not focus on the injury history kyle
shanahan did that yesterday here he is
talking about jimmy g
biggest thing with jimmy is his injuries
it's been very tough for us when he's
been hurt and um
you know it has happened two out of
these three years uh i mean and that's
where it starts and jimmy knows that i
have been very upfront with him with
everything and um you know we've been
zooming these last two weeks i'm excited
to get them in here coming up especially
when this draft's over um but i feel
very fortunate taking a rookie
quarterback that we do have a guy like
jimmy um that you know we didn't we you
know we didn't sign a guy who's capable
or has the history of being a starter
right away well we have a guy who every
time he's been a starter he's played at
a high level
so did they have that with jimmy while
adding a rookie quarterback gives us a
lot of leeway into this i'm not going to
set anything in stone but i know that's
a situation that it would be hard to to
get rid of i mean when you take a rookie
quarterback and you have a veteran like
jimmy who we know we can win with
just to move on from that is something
that
it's not easy to do that is a good
situation for us and i think that's
something that will be important to us
this year
we have to view those comments through
the lens that there is a strategic
component to everything definitely they
would like to get a return for jimmy g
the question is when do you get it do
you get it now do you hold on to him and
hope
that there's a fluke quarterback injury
in late august like the vikings had in
2016 where that opened the door for the
eagles to get a first round pick and a
fourth round pick for sam bradford who
supposedly was their week one starter
while the rookie carson wentz sat on the
bench look chris i don't care how it
falls when we're gonna we're gonna
witness how it falls
i can't imagine the 49ers ultimately
paying jimmy garoppolo 25 million this
year i think that if whoever they draft
checks the boxes passes the smell test
looks the part we get to late august
they're going to go to jimmy and they're
going to say hey jimmy we can't pay you
25 million this year we need you to cut
10 million off
or we're just gonna we're gonna release
you before week one and you're gonna
become a free agent with no takers with
no options with no spots to get yourself
properly ensconced so you can play this
year so if you want to be the starter
week one right you got to take 10
million less right now yeah there
there's a lot of interesting things
about this little aspect of this whole
trade the number three pick and all of
these type of things i mean first off
you know yeah
though
they're a team that i believe views
themselves as a super bowl team i mean
john lynch started off the press
conference by like well i think we have
a pretty good football team here we got
good depth and i know we got to stay
healthy and all that so
that's where i get back into like
i don't know do you keep a guy like
jimmy g to be the backup quarterback
just in case
something like that you know
my original thought or my heart goes no
because i just think it's going to cause
more problems like we've talked about
you know when the trade was first made
and all those type of things
you know that then i guess the next the
next aspect is just yeah when does it go
down when do you try to trade them right
do you try to do it now why teams are
the most desperate this weekend or do
you try to take the approach like you
know kind of like you said
i think there's got to be a little bit
of like hey first whoever we draft let's
let's let's make sure he gets in here
and
doesn't crap the bed right for lack of a
better thing to say or lives right or
lives right so we know he'll be the
quarterback or right so you do that and
all that but then yeah i would think
you'd start
if you if you check all the boxes and
okay whoever it is lance jones whatever
okay hey they came in they had a few
good practices they belong to be here
we're good i would think that's when
you try to trade jimmy g i mean that
would be by two cents there and you're
right mike i go back to that contract
i i'm i'm with you there i don't think
they're gonna be able to trade him
unless they fix that contract that would
be my two cents on that situation to go
along with it as well
it's the trent brown dynamic which
confused the hell out of me when the
patriots traded for brown early in free
agency and the raiders
uh got something for him and brown took
less it's the balance between
going somewhere now
you know how this movie's going to end
and i know how this movie is going to
end it's going to end with jimmy g
getting cut labor day weekend
potentially uh if not sooner so you take
less now you go to a new team now the
49ers get a reasonable return now right
and and they move forward without the
concern that george kittle raheem mostar
this guy that guy that guy that guy
shows up with their team jimmy g shirts
t-shirts on when when it's time to to
report to training camp that that's what
you want to avoid that split of opinion
and chris here's the other side of it
yeah they got a great team okay they got
a great team yeah super bowl ready super
bowl ready so let's go with the guy we
have then why the hell did you give up
all that stuff to go get
some quarterback that we're gonna find
out who it is it isn't even one guy it's
potentially three guys how do you strike
that balance you're either all in with
the new guy who presumably will be able
to play more than 10 games in a given
year
or you're going to ride this to its
conclusion with jimmy garoppolo because
otherwise you just go get a good backup
quarterback for jimmy garoppolo peter
said that yesterday they can't afford to
go into the season with you know one
quarterback injury away from disaster
like they've been right then just keep
jimmy g and go get a better backup don't
give up three first-round picks and a
third round pick to get the guy who may
or may not play this year well i think
they're telling you either way they've
had it with jimmy g i mean that
writing's on the wall there i mean how
can you play him that's my point well if
you've had it with him how can you put
him on the field i i don't think i don't
think ultimately they will you know the
scenario i'm talking about is him being
the backup quarterback i mean so you're
right mike i mean all the points i'm not
arguing arguing you here
i'm with you all the way i mean yes if
i'm running the 49ers or telling kyle
shanahan or talking to him i'm going no
at some point get rid of jimmy g and
bring somebody else in there to be the
backup that won't be as controversial
and divide the locker room and do all
the things that you've mentioned i mean
i think you're spot on you're no doubt
no doubt about it you know but he is a
good quarterback he is a starting
quarterback and i think like
the goal has to be at least to get
something from him right i'd be pissed
off if i'm shanahan or lynch and we get
to training camp and i'm like what we're
gonna have to cut them like we're not
gonna we didn't get anything for them
that's that would be disappointing and
we have teams right now that we know
have some
quarterback wants and needs out there
too
and that's where i just come back to
like your your main point mike the
contract
you know hey jimmy g does he want to go
back to new england and maybe have a
chance to play there against cam newton
well
bill belichick isn't going to pay him 25
million dollars a year to you right i
mean there's just no way he's not going
to do that and upset the locker room
between him right
right at most i'm with you so there's
that one so okay jimmy g if you want to
play you're gonna have to lower to go to
new england you know i don't know you
talk about like the other teams that
jump out to me mike you know we've
talked about the broncos
i don't know if they do that either to
want to pay 25 i have a hard time and
then there's the texans and the bears so
you got four teams out there to me as a
base fan guy that does this that i look
at to go i think you could legitimately
call these teams and strike up a
conversation and they might have some
legitimate interest in a jimmy g
yeah i don't disagree with that and that
may be where it's all headed you can't
put him on the field week one to back to
get back to the original point this mess
that they've kind of accidentally
created for themselves with who they're
going to take at that third overall pick
whoever you do pick now
and then if you
put jimmy g on the field week one and he
stays healthy and he runs that offense
right not because of any special
high-end tom brady skills he has yeah
because it's kyle shanahan
right yeah and then they get rolling
like they did in 2019 right and and
and
meanwhile the two guys you didn't take
are starting right and playing well
right the guy you gave up all that stuff
to get is stuck on the bench behind
garoppolo september becomes october it's
2019 all over again all of a sudden
they're eight and two and you're like
what do we do here right what did we do
we gave up three first round picks and a
third round pick when hey our guy was
jimmy garoppolo we just needed to give
him a chance we just needed you know it
was fluke injury stuff happens he's not
inherently fragile it just kind of
happens it can happen to anybody it's
football at the highest level guys get
injured and then you get swept up in
that
and then what do you do
especially if you end up having another
team that gets to the super bowl and
doesn't win it no let's say they get
there and they don't win it yeah what
the hell do you do next year yeah what
do you do i'm with you mike i mean that
that that was one of my points way back
when right about why you can't keep them
just because
that's a scary scenario they're a good
team shanahan's awesome on offense like
you said you can put a lot of cool you
know they stay healthy you can put a lot
of quarterbacks in football there in san
francisco they're going to win some
games and look good so yeah that would
be like the the worst thing that could
happen keep jimmy g
he plays
and or even let's just say like similar
the same thing too where
oh okay the starter the rookie does
start week one and gets a high ankle
sprain and now he's hurt now i gotta go
to jimmy g and now they run off let's
say nine out of ten games uh you're not
going to bench them you know and then
you oh now we're gonna do a playoff run
and like you're gonna have all that
controversy there that you're right mike
i'm with you i think it's way too dicey
to keep him on the roster and i would
expect that between now and really the
end of otas that there's gonna be you
know dialogue with a lot of teams
concerning jimmy g
that's the other risk they're taking
they don't know which of these guys from
the 2021 quarterback draft class is
going to be injury prone at the next
level you don't know until you put him
at the next level and he starts getting
hit by next level guys yeah that's right
i just don't know sam darnold's had
injury issues he's the guy of the ones
taken in 2018 that has that big red flag
over whether or not he's durable and can
play of course the mono was one of the
reasons but still availability
availability availability and here i
guess to tie the two threads together
this mystery at number three and the
mystery of jimmy g the fact that they've
embraced the mystery at the top of the
draft makes it even more imperative that
they get jimmy g the hell out of there
so they can go all in with whoever they
end up picking they cannot afford to not
go all in chris with that guy after
showing up at the showroom and saying we
came for the ferrari but we really like
the other two cars and we're probably
going to leave with the ferrari but we
really like the other two cars they
there's a disconnect between football
and business
you can't ignore the business side of it
you can't piss off your customers you
have to take that into account this gets
back to the social media point i'm not
saying be influenced by social media but
man you you have to find a way to
present these things to your fans in a
way that minimizes the chances of a
revolt and the way this is playing out
depending upon how they make these moves
they could find themselves in a mess
with their fan base if if if some stuff
happens yeah no doubt other than people
dying before sunday yeah uh and
hopefully we'll all be here by sunday
but but that it's very risky and i just
i wonder
chris when you consider all the
personalities yeah and all the brains
you put them all together i wonder if
they've really thought this through
to to the level that this discussion
takes it have they really thought it
through they got a lot of stuff to do
they're busy they got a bunch of players
to scout things take on life on their
own i wonder if they really thought
through the mess they potentially are
walking right into i i would have a hard
time
you know
not or what am i i don't want to twist
my words here i would have a hard time
thinking they didn't do their
really due diligence thought this
through again i don't know the specifics
behind all these conversations i can
tell you that i've been around the
shanahan family a lot i've been around
kyle and mike a lot
it's always football they're always
talking and of course
quarterback is their big topic of
conversation always too no matter what
organization they've been in no matter
what the time i've known them since the
time they it was the end of the john
elway to the start of the bryan greece
era that's when i i'm lear
i met them so i i would have a hard time
thinking this wasn't really well thought
out
and i i think really at a base level it
was still one guy that was in mind the
whole time but let's go to the store
like you said and just make sure
everything's good with all these other
cars and hey let me test drive a few of
the other ones just to make sure the one
i really wanted is the one i really
wanted and i think that's where we're
back to here i think and uh we'll see
where it goes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports